ex formación tras los ataques rusos en
la ciudad de rubíes de hombres con palas
remueven la tierra para sacar a sus
seres queridos de tumbas improvisadas
murieron durante el asedio de marzo
lilia y su esposo tardaron en llegar al
apartamento donde se encontraban sus
padres quedaron separados unos del lado
ruso y otros del ucraniano
kirchner mi madre ya se estaba muriendo
lo comprendí sus manos estaban azules a
su tez cetrina tenía ojeras y comprendí
que no podía comer ofrecía agua que
bebía con avidez
mi marido y yo cubrimos las ventanas y
al día siguiente mamá falleció
el entierro tuvo que ser de urgencia
afuera volaban las balas de la guerra
[Música]
no teníamos la pala ni ninguna otra
herramienta para el funeral
mi marido recorrió la zona y encontró
esta zanja la cubrimos con una manta e
intentamos llevarla pero pesaba
demasiado y había proyectiles por todas
partes era demasiado peligroso la
arrastramos y la enterramos sacar a
niveles ahora quieren trasladar los
cuerpos y llevarlos a un lugar
definitivo historias como éstas se
repiten las autoridades de la hora
autoproclamada república de lugansk que
logró su independencia con la ayuda rusa
ayudan en la búsqueda muchos hemos
estado trabajando en ruiz durante diez
días y exhumamos 104 conjuntos de restos
está claro que predominan las heridas de
metralla pero también hay heridas de
bala
estamos recogiendo material genético
para no tener que exhumar el cuerpo en
el futuro para los cuerpos desconocidos
siempre recogemos material genético y si
hay alguna duda o algún familiar podemos
identificar a la persona en un
laboratorio
por un total de seis cadáveres fueron
desenterrados
según las autoridades habría otras 500
fosas no oficiales en rue business